avete detto preso o no persona tradita o
no ho messo tutte basta attenzione ai
perso per 99 volte la simulazione nella
vita reale inizierà tra quindici secondi
per interrompere le iniziali ma che
succede vitale vita è fatto qua e ci
stiamo giocando
supermario che fra poco partira la
simulazione a simulazione remix ma non
funziona
[Applauso]
massimo con la mia parola che è successo
di nuovo
siamo nuovamente in super mario della
vita reale
wow abbiamo raccogliere le monete allora
dài guarda per vincere la partita
raccoglie tutte le monete ma se perdi
tre vite rimarrà intrappolato nel gioco
buona fortuna che accanto i nemici
brilliance e raccogliamo tutte le monete
cerchiamo di non perdere le vite io non
amo nei campionati soprattutto al piano
di sotto dei bomber mandiamo abbiamo gli
amici ma cosa intenderà con nemici
non lo so proprio mordente non portare
nessun artista ok io vado qui sopra o
ketchup
si no
[Musica]
[Applauso]
un po non ci arrivo un idea
ciao berlino dove ci fai qua bene ho
ripulito questa stanza da tutte le
monete
andiamo a vedere l'altra stanza adesso
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ehi ma tutto tutto dimettere se non c'è
mai finiti denunciare quindi fino a qua
madonna air in camera da letto
stai attento i funghetti per terra ok
[Musica]
i nemici stanno aumentando per terra non
posso più scendere d'acqua
cosa faccio adesso forse è meglio
aspettare qua
speriamo che i cani si sbrighi ei vita
[Risate]
[Musica]
di tale dove sei
ma in questa stanza non ci sono monete
quindi vuol dire che anita già passata
di qua credo di sì andiamo a controllare
nella sostanza allora è come se questo
fosse il mio castello il castello della
principessa peach dire per passare mire
mario a salvarmi cioè vitale ci sono
troppi nemici ora giu spero che arrivi
presto
e così finalmente ciao che ci vai là
sopra mi sono rifugiata qua perché i
miei amici non possono salire a qua
sopra
ma stai per caso parlando dei funghi sai
perché io prima li ho visti un paio
sotto e favo che fossero buoni da
mangiare invece è venuto altro una lista
e quindi ora assoluto dividervi che me
l'ha fatto ora il fungo che lo devo
mangiare in fermata
pensavi che fossero da mangiare ai
sprecato una vita così a punto pare si
parla che rischi di rimanere
intrappolato qui per te se rimane
intrappolato qui per sempre non ci
saranno più le cose da mangiare lo sai
ora devi trovare un modo per far vision
evitando tutti i nemici che non so come
scegliere d'acqua
ok ok ora ci pensa un momento ed elabori
un piano per venire a salvarti non so
cosa posso fare io arriverò alla
principessa saltando su questi funghetti
e una volta lì lo potrò salvare si son
sicuro che funzionerà questo piano
andiamo
[Musica]
memopal si riuscì tutti sono tutti i
funghetti tutti i nemici bravo come puoi
vedere ho già raccolto tutte le monete
qua di studiare dove andiamo a
raccoglierle e adesso dobbiamo uscire
fuori ad accoglierle è vero possiamo
vedere se in giardino esistono altre
monete si io per fortuna ho tre vite
quindi tu devi stare molto attento
altrimenti rimarrà intrappolato qua per
sempre no no no no no se poi senza cibo
voglio pertanto tutte le vite rifare le
stesse cibo andiamo in giardino a teramo
via
[Musica]
io ho due vite cui solo una vita lo
affronto io ok ciò non tanati che
facciamo fallire
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma poi lasciate un bel mi piace perché
se questo vi di raggiungere i 30 mila mi
piace ci sarà una terza parte di
supermario nella vita reale non avete
visto la prima parte cliccate qui per
vederla e se volete vedere i nostri
altri video dei videogiochi nella vita
reale di gatte quale volete vedere gli
altri video di supermario nella vita
reale cliccate qua per un altro video
clicca qui se mila casadina che
preferisci e la visione
[Musica]